all right i want to start today with
what's happening in the
israeli-palestinian conflict where once
again we have another
major flare-up and no clarity at this
time whether this will be
on the order of weeks or months in
duration or
possibly even longer now normally i
would just
jump right into the story and what's
going on and my perspective
but because of what i came into my
office to this morning uh dozens and
dozens of emails and messages from
people
speculating as to why i haven't talked
about this yet
making all sorts of of accusations and
allegations some of them very
just sort of sad in terms of what they
imply
people think is my life on sort of a
day-to-day basis and i've not
spoken about this recent flare-up much
yet
only three times on the recent bonus
show
and a couple times on recent live
streams i've not spoken much about it
yet because i've not felt that i have
much to add or
say that's different from my analysis
the last time we talked about it but
i received a couple of emails from long
time viewers
respectfully saying this feels like it
could be different this time and it
would be great for you to update your
take on what's going on
and so i'm going to do it i also receive
dozens of furious
and often emails playing on anti-semitic
tropes referring to me as a zionist jew
pig
and things that are even worse that i
won't say because of our radio
affiliates
so that they don't have to bleep things
um and people saying
uh everything from you are not talking
about it because you're
scared you'll be exposed as the zionist
pig that you are
or it's financial reasons or whatever so
i'm under no illusion that those people
will be satisfied with this segment
unless i unilaterally put the sole blame
for a 70-year conflict at the hands
of genocidal evil israel and anyone who
knows me knows
i would never give such childish black
and white takes on any issue and so
those people who have been emailing me
saying
i deserve to lose my show because i
haven't yet talked about it
i'm sure we'll shift to saying i should
lose my show because of what i say today
this segment is not for them clearly um
there
there were some really wacky things
being emailed to me maybe on other
platforms as well i've really only
looked at emails but maybe things are
crazy on the discord or on reddit i
don't know
uh people saying well clearly i'm not
saying anything because i'm afraid of
the blowback from from taking a position
my audience won't like
that's never stopped me before on the
show what i have said before is
if there's an issue that's unnecessarily
inflammatory
that most of my audience seems not to
care about i would consider skipping it
but i've done dozens of segments on the
israeli-palestinian conflict then i got
emails saying david
you know you should really have the the
uh courage
to do what this other jewish person did
and that other jewish person they were
able to put aside their jewish bias
and take the correct view on this which
is israel is the only problem in israel
in some cases even should not exist as
some people emailed me
david why does your judaism blind you
you can't be a fair arbiter here because
you're jewish
this is the same argument that
right-wingers made
during the fight for gay rights saying
of course gay people want gay marriage
they're biased you can't listen to them
they can't get past their personal
connection to the issue
and it borders on anti-semitic because
it plays on the trope of a dual loyalty
that american jews
have a conflicting loyalty to israel
most jews of course have never been to
israel i've been there once six years
ago
i don't live there uh you won't be able
to engage with me
on things like can't you put aside your
judaism and take the correct position
uh that's um that's an identity politics
rabbit hole
it's trash and i don't engage in that so
i want to focus on what's been taking
place now one last thing
and again i hate that i even have to do
this but you should see what i stepped
into in my inbox when i when i got in
this morning
i also got emails saying david you're
motivated uh by money
so you want to avoid losing money if you
give an unpopular take
and so that's why you're hiding your
view on the subject and some people
writing and saying you know david you
used to cover the israeli-palestinian
conflict because you had a smaller
audience
and you made less money now there's too
much money at stake
i'm going to ignore for a second again
the anti-semitic trope of jews and money
to say that over time as the show has
been more and more more successful
financial considerations are less
and less a part of anything i do at this
point i
never chose stories based on money
i chose stories based on do i feel like
talking about it do i feel like i have
something to add
is this something my audience would be
interested in that's it it's just my
show and i pick the stories every day
financial incentives never dictated
story choice
they especially don't right now and by
the way
if lots of people are interested in the
topic then doing the story would bring
money no matter what i say
hate watching is still watching it still
makes just as much money
so it's not only an incorrect take it's
wrong on the facts as well
all of that now out of the way all of
the reasons
why i've not been not doing a story now
out of the way
let's talk about what's going on and if
you want to engage with me on this
engage
with what i'm actually saying not
anything else that you're bringing in
okay there are arguably two catalysts to
this flareup
and both have israel to blame both
have israel to blame both have israel to
blame
can i find ways to maybe say the
catalysts are more to
say i could but they feel disingenuous
to me the narrow catalyst for this
flareup is israel the first is that a
squad of israeli police officers
entered the al-aqsa mosque in jerusalem
this is a very volatile place
i was there a few years ago non-muslims
are only allowed
at al-aqsa during certain time periods
then i don't know what's going on now
i was lucky to be there at just the
right time we were allowed in the
al-aqsa mosque is
controlled by the jordanian authority
within the old city of jerusalem
one of the most interesting places i've
ever been the old city in general and
al-aqsa itself
fascinating historical places a squad of
israeli police officers
entered the aksa mosque in jerusalem
brushed the palestinian jordanian
attendants aside
went across the courtyard and cut the
cables
to loudspeakers that were broadcasting
prayers
during ramadan disastrous idea now why
did they do it
the explanation is the israeli president
not prime minister the israeli president
was delivering a speech at the western
wall
on israeli memorial day you had ramadan
prayers conflicting with a memorial day
speech so the speakers were cut it's a
terrible idea now you can argue
and and unfortunately this is how
intractable this conflict is where many
of us would say oh come on just
you know give this speech somewhere else
or turn down the music or whatever
the turn now the prayers or whatever
that that's not the way this conflict
works and if you've been
following the 70-plus year history of it
you you would see why this explodes
uh but uh i understand thinking what how
is that
uh what was the first catalyst then
we had the upcoming eviction of six
families from the sheikh
zarah neighborhood a palestinian
neighborhood in east jerusalem
that led to protests then there was a
police raid on the al-aqsa mosque on may
7th police officers with tear gas
stun grenades rubber-tipped bullets went
into the moss compound
around 8 pm local time uh and this set
off
hours of clashes with protesters there
were hundreds of injuries according to
medics that were on site as reported by
the new york times
the police say that the stone throwers
started it worshipers are saying
the israeli police started it and then
things exploded as usual each side has
their own view on who the
real wrongdoers are and who is merely
reacting to the other side another
intractable uh bedrock
of every single one of these flare-ups
and there's plenty to go around
dozens and dozens of hamas rockets
coming over from gaza
even reaching tel aviv israel doing
bombings as is always the case israel's
actions leading to more death
now let me say one thing about this
whole disproportionate response thing
that
often is is mentioned yes israel's
response is disproportionate that's
absolutely true
israel is far better armed than the
hamas terrorists
in gaza that's absolutely true and
whenever this happens
there tend to be more deaths as a result
of israeli action
that's absolutely true and that's
horrible i think
that we should also be honest with
ourselves
that some of the people who say well if
six palestinians die
and one israeli dies it's a
disproportionate response
i don't think they would be pleased if
the numbers were the same i mean
would we really be seeing a different
reaction from people
if uh 12 palestinians and 12 israelis
died would then would that no longer be
a factor
i don't think so so of course the
response is disproportionate
responses are a common thing in many
conflicts
ethnic political military etc it doesn't
mean it's good
but to focus on that when obviously the
side that's better armed is likely to do
more damage
i don't think it helps us understand
what's going on
any better now then israel did another
completely harebrained thing
blowing up a building in which the
associated press was working in gaza
saying there were hamas there now
maybe there were hamas maybe they
weren't israeli authorities did call and
say
get out because we're going to hit this
building whatever
is the case hamas is in all sorts of
different places
and it just seems idiotic to me to
target this building
because it does exactly what israel's
opponents want to say israel does which
is
suppress criticism and news of what's
happening in gaza and
in some literal sense that's exactly
what happens when you blow up a building
out of which the ap is working so
disastrous idea absolutely condemnable
so let's go through these things first
and i'll tell you where i stand and pay
close attention
because again i'm not going to engage in
responses that mischaracterize what i
say
i am and have been against evictions and
settlements
period for the 25 years i've been
following this conflict
there's no there's there's no mitigator
i'm just
i'm against it i condemn it this current
israeli government
makes me sick and has for a long time
and settlements are a big part of that
one thing that is important and that
tons of people are missing
are that much like the palestinian
people
are different from hamas and the
palestinian authority
and the ultra radical palestinians the
israeli people
israel as a country and the current
administration are three different
things
when during the iraq war years some
europeans wrongly saw all americans as
warmongers who wanted to go to iraq
we all understood why that didn't make
sense we know the difference intuitively
between the trump administration the
united states as a country
and americans as individuals and yet
more than half the emails i received
about this
don't seem to understand or make that
distinction between the netanyahu
administration
israel as a country and the israeli
people uh
using the three terms interchangeably
and that's just a fundamental
misunderstanding of what's going
on how can we even have a remotely
sensible conversation about this
conflict
if you interchangeably assign blame or
characterize
three separate entities the current
administration israel as a country and
the israeli people as one
one and the same the evictions from east
jerusalem are at the heart of this
and i'm 100 percent against that uh they
are illegal by international law period
settlers are radical extremists i share
nothing with them
i am diametrically opposed settlers are
a tiny fraction of israeli jews who are
just a portion of world
jews unless someone says i'm for the
settlements
i assume that uh they are not because
this is such a radical
uh and relatively fringe group settlers
are in a sense massive provocateurs
shameless ones at that and sadly right
now
the netanyahu government is benefiting
from
the settlers and so they are allowing
this to happen
second i am 100 against the netanyahu
government which i believe
is allowing this to happen for the
benefit of benjamin netanyahu
the depraved and disgusting right-wing
prime minister
netanyahu knows his days are numbered he
was unable to form a government so he is
allowing this to happen now
because this is how he operates look at
the chaos you need me he pulled this
before an election
some years ago now this is when maybe
some people
want me to start saying who is to blame
and to what degree david
please say this conflict is 99 israel or
say it's all hamas or you are a
hamas sympathizer nothing is that simple
what i will tell you is what i see is
the most likely path to peace for the
long term
and it requires both netanyahu and likud
not to be in power on the israeli side
and somehow
for hamas to be removed from power in
gaza but not replaced by hezbollah which
is essentially as bad but better armed
so here's my perspective if you said
what is the most likely path to peace
and this is why i didn't have much to
say initially in this
because fundamentally the path to peace
has not changed in my view
so starting with the big picture anyone
who thinks that there should be no
palestinian state in the future
is just not a productive participant
here the palestinians
need a state of their own a contiguous
one which i will get to
anyone who thinks there should be no
country of israel
is also not a productive participant and
if you really want to see a situation
where many people would die
it would be a a real attempt uh
but by serious players um to make israel
no longer
a country so the palestinian people
deserve a state and to live in peace
and the israeli people do as well and
right now
neither side is being led by those who
benefit from peace or who want it
until that changes nothing will change
so the first question is who's in charge
in a hypothetical peaceful situation in
israel
it's not netanyahu and it's not likud
okay on the palestinian side hamas must
be replaced by a more secular
palestinian authority immediately
hezbollah replacing hamas won't get us
to serious
peace possibilities does mahmoud abbas
have a role to play there
currently overseeing the west bank maybe
i'm open to that it doesn't seem hamas
is open to that
when you look at how long a boss has
been around i think you can also
increasingly make the case that abbas is
not a likely
arbiter to a longer term piece abbas
has also given you know lie riddled
speeches at the un
so has benjamin netanyahu to the extent
that abbas
might be a productive partner i'm open
to it being a mahmud abbas-led
uh coalition government west bank and
gaza
but i don't know how feasible that
really is
um in all likelihood you are going to
need to have
the law of return for jews to israel
maintained
and a law of return established for the
future palestinian state now
the entire point of israel is since jews
uh
were kicked out and discriminated of so
many parts of the world for so long
that's a place jews know they can go
even if
hungary turns extremely right-wing
anti-semitic or
anti-semitic or whatever the case may be
there also is going to have to be
i believe some ability
for palestinians to return to israel
something's going to have to be conceded
mathematically
and this is something yasser arafat
talked about in the 90s
it's not going to be 5 million
palestinians it's just not going to
happen
so we need a combination of some
reasonable
palestinian return to what will be the
state of israel
certainly the palestinian state will be
able to decide
who is allowed to go there as well
anyone who wants to move back to gaza or
the west bank would be free to do so
if the palestinian authority wants to
allow it now ahud barak
in the past proposed a symbolic number
of palestinian return to israel
and significant financial reparations
that's something that could be looked at
uh i but but that's more details once we
get past
sort of the big uh uh questions
in terms of the land what are the
borders right
um i believe the most likely uh
path to peace will come with something
that is more or less the clinton
proposed borders
uh or symbol which is similar to a lot
of the recent ideas not the trump ideas
forget trump trump
anything trump said is in the trash the
palestinian territory would include the
west bank gaza and east jerusalem
yes east jerusalem there are some
problems
with exactly what the limits of east
jerusalem would be because they are
disputed but
let's imagine if we got to this point
they could be agreed upon
east jerusalem would become the capital
of the palestinian state
i think that has to be conceded and the
caveat would be the jewish quarter of
east jerusalem should remain
under israeli sovereignty we could do
just a whole show on this but
if you look at the desecration of the
jewish quarter when it was not under
israeli control from i believe 49 to 67
you can read more about that i think
that is a caveat
on settlements i mean just all
settlements have to stop immediately
uh israel has to agree in principle to
remove
settlements that uh can be removed
and to offer meaningful land swaps for
those that cannot now as a practical
reality and i also go back to what
arafat said about this
not all the settlements at this point
can be realistically removed i hate that
that's disgusting
uh but if you say david you're the
pragmatist
negotiator morally i have no problem
with removing every settlement and i
know the talking point is well these are
people's homes yes they're people's
homes that were built in violation of
international law
and they never should have been built uh
yasser arafat
had the idea that keeping the larger
settlements
in exchange for meaningful land swaps
would be okay
that's probably something that would
would have to be negotiated
and then um certainly on the other hand
you know all settlements have to stop um
i believe the blockade has to be lifted
to gaza
you do have to have some way of
preventing
um uh weapon materials from being
brought in it has to be negotiated but
the blockade as a sign of good faith at
least initially has to be lifted of
course
palestinians have to immediately all
palestinian groups
have to stop all rockets immediately
stop the tunnel building
uh so on and so forth hamas and other
groups have to demilitarize gaza as part
of a peace agreement
we saw in the two-year period after the
withdrawal of israel from gaza but
before the blockade was put in place
you know thousands of rockets so there
has to be a demilitarization but the
gaza blockade has to be removed and as
long as the demilitarization
and no rockets are held to the deal the
the blockade has to be removed
how do you hold people to that i don't
know that has to be figured out
and then lastly the eventual peace
agreement has to include
that all claims are being renounced and
it is the end of the conflict period
because the problem you run into
is you have some sort of an agreement in
principle
but not all claims are renounced and
then when the agreement is violated
everybody goes back to pretending like
this was never
identified as the end of the conflict if
there's going to be a serious deal
once the right players come to the table
and as i already mentioned who those are
is complicated
uh it has to be determined that that is
the end of the conflict and in the
future
that allows any violator of the
agreement either on the israeli or the
palestinian side to be held to account
some non-binding thing is not going to
get us what we need
if you want to react address these
specific points
all insults anti-semitic responses
blanket replies like what i had over the
weekend in my email zionist pig
it's all going to be ignored the winners
here are netanyahu
and hamas chaos from which netanyahu
can say you need me to protect you
that's a gift
hamas justified in its brutal grip on
the gazan people
because look at what israel is doing to
us we're the only ones who can respond
with the rockets
the palestinian people lose here the
israeli people lose
bibi wins and hamas wins i look forward
to hearing your thoughts